guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters
inshallah help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their
revelation to fast whether you obey the
bible or not the quran must be false
because if the bible's true the quran is
false if the bible's false the quran is
telling you to obey a false document
at no point in the quranic discourse
does allah subhanahu wa ta'ala say or in
any hadith does the prophet say
that the the bible is is what is
referred to
okay
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed
products the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah we've
got uh another reaction video that was
sent to me on instagram
um if you guys have any reaction videos
you would like me and hijab or zeeshan
to do send them on my instagram show
that's where i usually look uh this
one's quite interesting because it's a
lot this is a missionary on stage and
they use this a lot and i think i don't
think they really understand it yeah
so he's showing the quranic dilemma
uh let's watch for ourselves and i think
the questioner is a muslim you ready
um
do you think that they don't know who i
am i know this is your channel
i need to introduce
judaism and christianity how would you
respond to that
he said that islam and christianity or
islam and judaism are what now
say that again a little closer to mike
if you could islam
is the complete version of uh christian
christianity and judaism or like a quran
contains both
uh in one book i would first ask what do
you mean by that
and then how did you come to that
conclusion just those two questions
because again he has to support
first of all has to clarify and then
support what he says
and he's probably a muslim who's trying
to say that islam
is the final revelation to mankind
and i would ask him for evidence of that
why do you think islam is the final
revelation to mankind
in fact you can even use the quran to
point out that it's not
because in the quran chapter 5 verse 68
and in other places
uh surah 5 68's a chapter it says o ye
people of the book who are the people of
the book
christians and the jews you have no
ground to stand on unless you stand on
the law and the gospels in other words
the quran tells
christians and jews to obey the old
testament in the new testament the law
and the gospels
now if we go back to the old testament
and the new testament
it leaves no room for the koran
so the quran is saying obey the bible
but the bible says no no more revelation
it's done so if the quran
is saying obey the bible then the quran
is false
or islam is false i should say right
if the quran is telling christians and
jews to obey the bible
and as muslims will say it's been
corrupted
the quran is also false in other words
this called the quranic dilemma
whether you obey the bible or not the
quran must be false
because if the bible's true the quran is
false if the bible's false the quran is
telling you to obey a false document
books of the new testament where you
have you know up until the book of
revelation by the way some other books
were going to be added but then they
decided who is this guy to tell would
you respect athanasius who is he
to tell us what should be the word god
of word of god and how could it be
that for all this time the patristic
fathers and the ecumenical writers
yeah through 300 years yeah they didn't
know what the entire bible was they were
debating it so
you want us to believe so the important
question is if who are they to say
that's the bible and who are you
to tell us that the injeel that allah's
talking about is the bible that you're
talking about of course
look the word bible is like i said it's
understood as the old testament new
testament nowhere in the quran is that
word mentioned what the quran is talking
about
is the original torah and the injil so
there's a pro in his premise so when he
says the bible
when allah talks about like the people
of the book okay we know who they're
talking about that's clear
but when allah talks about injury and
torah his premise is false because he's
not talking about the bible that you
have in here we believe in
the doctrine of tariff if you want to
put it that way right it's a doctrine
which says that the books that the
christians and jews have
now has been muharram has been corrupted
and changed
yes there are too many verses in the
quran to even start beginning
to name them um
so go to those who write the book with
their own hands and say this is from god
so that they can they can get with their
miserly prize
or miserly prize or in the other verses
it says
they they distort the words out of them
what do those are so many
there's so many but let's let's let's
not even go there the quran in the same
chapter that he's talking about
it says that the quran is
it's a guardian now actually one of
god's names is the guardian right
which means that he checks to see which
of the things
in the in the scriptures that we have
now passed down from the previous
dispensations
which of those things are acceptable and
which are not that's why we don't say
everything the bible is false
anything which matches what we believe
and we believe in and if something
doesn't match
and it goes again if it contradicts it
then we know it's false because the
quran says
x and the bible says why so we know that
thing is false if it neither confirms
nor rejects the prophet actually told us
what to do he says
don't belie them do not say that they're
telling the truth and do not believe
them in other words you have an agnostic
have an agnostic attitude towards those
things which the quran has not mentioned
so we have a a a full template on how to
deal with
um those books that have made it from
the previous dispensations into the
canons that we have today
but at no point in the quranic discourse
does allah subhanahu wa ta'ala say or in
any hadith does the prophet say
that the the bible is is what is
referred to
okay so okay so it's very clear that
when it's talking about allah talks
about
the injil it's not talking about the
current bible that you have so that's
the first fallacy
okay number two when allah refers to
them so for example in a group of jews
who came to the prophet peace be upon
him
and allah says it mentions in the quran
where allah told them to refer back to
their book don't you have the torah
now this is a specific instance where
they came because
in in their books and it's very
important because what allah is trying
to signify here
um and we know from the hadith of the
prophet peace be upon him is this very
instance was about a adulterous
man or a woman and obviously they came
to the prophet for judgment and they
would not come to the prophet usually
because they don't believe him to be a
prophet
but because they were trying to sway out
of the capital punishment that is
in their books they came to the prophet
so the prophet sallam said
why don't you go to your book yeah now
he's using this as
one of those things to support and be
like well hold on a second you're
probably saying
torah he mentioned torah allah as well
but the reason why allah
allah is saying that in the quran and we
have a hadith of the prophet peace be
upon him explaining the situation
is because the prophet peace be on the
scene go to your books in your books
it's very clear what it says basically
in a nutshell
why are you trying to avoid the the the
ruling that you have in your scripture
so that doesn't mean that for example it
affirms
uh for example that the whole thing is
telling you in a specific instance stop
being
you know clever trying to be clever
about it and judge god's
commandments go to your book what is it
in your book go and apply that
and another thing that he mentioned in
there what was the verse he said in
surah
the verse um
okay this this you're not you're not
upon anything except if you
if you um uphold the torah
yes so we believe in the torah so then
we believe in the indian so when they
say that they had the torah at the
prophet's time
telling them to go to the book how could
you say it's corrupted when
allah is telling them to go back to the
book no because remember allah he says
if you look at we just look from chapter
5 and verse 40 to
verse 17. just read that in your own
time you will see it's very clear what
is being said here right
that you have these previous books that
have been sent
but that the quran is the guardian over
those things over those books
and that we believe in that we as part
of the faith of muslims we believe that
jesus was originally given
an injil yeah moses was originally given
a torah yeah so we do believe that you
have to believe in those books and that
you have to uphold those books but do we
have those books
no now we don't have those books there's
b they've been muharraf they have
not not just by the by the islamic
contention
but by almost practically look at bruce
metzger's works look at anybody who's
done anything on biblical uh sorry on um
uh what do you call it criticism text
criticism yeah yeah text criticism is an
entire field
right yeah and the assumption of it is
that the the
the old testament and the new testament
both of them are not by one author like
you have something called documentary
hypothesis yeah
which is that all these different
authors came back and they kind of made
a documentary style book
so in a nutshell brother and sisters you
can see that his premise is flawed in
the beginning and also for example
it's actually i believe it's a quranic
prophecy that we we i think we miss a
lot of the times in the tao as well
is that allah is saying that the
scriptures are corrupted
and the christians themselves are coming
and saying our scriptures are corrupted
that's actually a prophecy if you think
about it
because that affirms the quranic
knowledge yeah
no it's not only that because if the
bible wasn't corrupted what is allah
talking about allah
the people of the day i mean the prophet
and before that they didn't have this
notion of a corrupted bible
yeah now it's now because of tax
criticism this notion is widespread
so what was in the quran a thousand
hundred years ago
the the christians and jews didn't
appreciate as much as they are forced to
appreciate it
no yeah maybe they're not aware of this
and maybe they weren't aware of it so
about it so in a nutshell problem says
allah
there's no contradiction when allah
tells us that the people of the book
have corrupted
their scripture and that in specific
instances allah is telling them to refer
back to their book
out of to show their hypocrisy that not
only do you corrupt your book but you
don't even want to abide by the law that
you have in there
because it goes against your standards
the punishment of the old testament is
very clear
stoning to death it's as simple as that
for adultery but you don't want to apply
that which shows
that the the jews and the christians at
that time specifically
this is what they were doing and that's
all allah showing so i think we've
debunked that
claim and hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if they have any other
questions do share this with your
christian
friends uh uh until next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh